hello hi Marjorie it's day seven without
Heating in marjorie's home it's cold in
here isn't it it really is very cold yes
outside the temperature is below
freezing inside it feels just the same
all I've got is that microwave to cook
in I can't do things but normally do I
can't go in the shower can't do anything
it is terrible I've never known anything
like it
something to be freezing man there's
something some shoveling now
but oh dear you just don't know what to
do
you know I mean I'm I've got clothes on
there for two hers is one of 2 000 homes
in Sheffield cut off from gas supplies a
burst water pipe meant hundreds of
thousands of liters entered the gas
Mains and caused widespread disruption
oh my God a major incident was declared
as those responsible tried to keep
people safe from the cold
there potentially could be a worst case
scenario here
how does that make you feel that we
could potentially go down that road that
risk is precisely why we've declared a
major incident and why we're doing
everything we can to make sure that that
isn't the case so heaters are out there
we've made sure that vulnerable
residents have access to blankets and to
um to to thermals as we face this cold
snap it's clear these people in
Sheffield will be amongst the worst
affected in the country but up and down
the UK many people face hiked energy
bills and could struggle to heat their
homes and it's the impact on health
which is a major concern
it's those on the lowest income that
will likely suffer this winter but with
temperatures expected to stay below
freezing for a week in many areas the
government is issuing an additional 25
pound cold winter payment to those who
need it most Charities on the ground say
it isn't enough we know that lots of
families are making big sacrifices at
the moment and for some families there
just isn't enough money to make ends
meet they haven't got enough money to
buy the food that they need by the
clothes that they and their kids need
and have the heating on the advice from
Health bosses is to keep rooms heated
above 18 degrees for many that will be
near impossible particularly as the sun
sets the cold bites and this Arctic
blast we're facing is making a tough
winter even tougher in demand Rasheed
Sky News Sheffield